honestly i miss her so much like she
brought so much life into this house the
cavalcik family know how devastating the
theft of a pet can be good girl their
two-year-old french bulldog tina was
stolen from their car in may and hasn't
been found i don't think people realize
that like how
heartbreaking it is
to
to have a family member taken from you
because tina is our family member she's
not just a dog she's not just a pet
she was a part of our family honestly
and we are not whole
without her
previously pets were legally classed as
property like a phone
the government now says that didn't
recognize the trauma pet theft inflicts
on the animal and its owner what we're
doing today is recognizing that creating
a specific offence of pet abduction and
i think that'll make it easier for us to
record this crime keep track of it and
also easier to prosecute it as well the
pet theft task force also recommends
streamlining england's microchip
database
it comes after a rise in pet theft
during the pandemic
last year around 2 000 dog thefts were
reported to the police
seventy percent of all recorded animal
thefts involve dogs
prices of popular breeds like french
bulldogs have shot up by around 89
percent making them popular targets for
criminals there are the the instances of
dogs being stolen for
the purposes of breeding um
which is the the more organized elements
of the of the crime where
groups are stealing dogs and putting
them into a breeding cycle to
to fund the puppy trade the cavalcik
family hopes the proposals will prevent
other families going through their pain
and say they won't stop looking for tina
we continue to fight and we will fight
until tina is found like i promise you
she will come home to us one day
jemima walker sky news